bock auf eine deprimierende forsa
umfrage zwei drittel der ungeimpften in
deutschland wollen sich auch in den
nächsten monaten in keinem fall impfen
lassen 89 prozent von denen sagen es
habe keinerlei einfluss auf ihre
impfentscheidung wenn intensivstationen
wieder an kapazitätsgrenzen kommen
sympathisch im sinne von zum kotzen
vorschlag vorschlag wir genießen jetzt
einfach mal das leben so lange es dauert
zum beispiel an diesem
halloween-wochenende
till reiners präsentiert die
gruseligsten halloween kostüme
guck mal ich hier dieses jahr als locker
und super scary und das kostüm haben wir
ja alle noch da und man sitzt im sessel
dusche ich mehr und ist nun auch
frittierte hühner herrsche erst wollte
ich die verkleidung in den keller packen
aber jetzt kommt ja pandemie der
ungeimpften und zwar so will es die
politik zeitgleich mit dem ende der
pandemischen lage dieser virologe ist
dagegen drückt sie ja warum geschickt
aus das ist halt ein symbol es wird
suggeriert quasi freedom day von hinten
einführen und das war halt nicht das
kann keiner wollen nicht gruselig genug
diversen
der untote von der intensivstation
intensivpfleger nur echt mit richtigen
augenringe von denen gibt es immer
weniger ein drittel will im nächsten
jahr aufhören warum bloß leute einfach
mal den burnout als motto auf begreifen
leben am limit wer in dem job nicht
selber pflegebedürftig wird arbeitet
nicht makellos meine meinung nächste
kostüme die
leute keine uniform ich meine auch nicht
uniformiert ist mein und informiert ich
gehe halt josua kimmig der umkämpfte
bayern star lässt sich nicht impfen
dabei hat der mann noch remmert
abwehrkräfte ich sag nur 0 5 gegen
gladbach
wer noch im letzten jahr völlig zurecht
sagte ich glaube wir sollten jetzt alle
zusammen daran aber dann soll ich mal
dass dieses virus bekämpft wird dass wir
dann sollte ich mal möglichst schnell
wieder in unser alltagsleben
zurückkehren können ja und dafür lässt
man sich impfen ja ich mache erst
mittleres wunder reaktion wicona aber
lässt sich da nicht impfen das ist so
als wenn bill gates privaten iphone
benutzt kenne ich sagt empfehlen
langzeitstudien dabei treten
nebenwirkungen wenn überhaupt von
stunden oder tage nach der impfung auf
wozu ich ja gerne mal eine
langzeitstudie hätte wäre was passiert
eigentlich wenn man ganz oft einen ball
gegen den kopf kriegt
das nennt man wissenschaft ich sage ja
alles noch nicht gruselig genug ok dann
kommt hier das shock kostüm schlechthin
julian reichelt ist das geil ist das
geil so menz wer möchte alle sein
volontariat und habe mir machen
[Applaus]
hallo leute ich bin's der heute-show
[Musik]
hersteller wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß
und liebten - wollt dann abonniert jetzt
den kanal
was zur hölle ist minimal hersteller
[Musik]